hello everybody my name is
[Laughter]
hello everybody my name is welcome back
to rebel and evil
um uh my auto save was a little bit
behind so i guess we got to go through
uh this this scenario again
i i'm sorry you know i gotta backtrack a
little bit why is my mouth still here
it's really in the way
god i've gotta watch through this again
all this for a child who isn't even here
yeah you know what the hell do you
ungrateful selfish wretch you come into
my
house you lay your filthy man hands
on my daughters and now you even try to
steal
my property
how dare i indeed how dare i indeed
because i will hunt you and i will
break you all right you know promises
promises never be kept
uh something about lies anywho
back to whatever the hell we're doing
down in this basement here
you know chance encounters be that as it
may
i know that there's a world of hurt
waiting for me somewhere around this
cataclysmically depressing castle
sure is convenient that globally
everything's yellow taped up so that i
know exactly where i'm going
i don't even know where i am but at
least i know where i'm going
anybody else want some stab anybody else
want to keep in helping a stab
why is the music so dramatic
not like anything terrible is happening
here it's all perfectly normal
nothing to worry about where the hell am
i
why am i able to unlock it all from the
inside
hey wow you got down here quick
ribbons okay before you ever
see man people really don't like me
having hands oh
we're doing this now oh
oh demotress house
the power the power everybody the power
oh my goodness you see in this power can
i get that back can i can i get that
back
can i get that back oh
boy
not fast enough
just another hang on i gotta whip
something up here you like cooking i'm a
great cook
my right hand is unusual
uh-huh well i guess i won't turn around
man their power is so respectable
god you just gotta respect the level of
power that's
thundering down the halls
oh
okay here we go can i use my severed
hand on it
oh please hurry please oh hello
mask of sorrow i got it
i'm going up oh
running will get you nowhere
well i seem to be somewhere you know
that'll do it that'll fix it
how you explain that one what kind of
magic liquid is it
what is it no no
no even the jacket has sealed itself up
there's no way
who's crumble oh there you are okay hang
on one second i gotta make sure it's all
recording
what in the heck in hell just
happened how do you figure that one out
is it all good now am i good what kind
of miracle fluid
what is it whatever man whatever it's
all good
oh i can make a land mine i can make two
land mines
take that madame domitrisk all right let
me
hey where did you come from hey pal what
you doing
hey what's up
oh double ow hey look you could cut my
head off and it
just splashed some goose on me and i'm
fine you know what i
i think the days of knifing it up are
over
why do that when i'm such a sick
shot oops
ah can i take that sword by the way it'd
be much better than my knife
uh let me go back to the shopkeep real
quick
hey whoo oh hey whoo
maybe i could just farm up some stuff i
guess not that there'd be a purpose to
it but
i don't know if they just perpetually
spawn or anything
in the butt anybody in the butt
it's not worth it they will just keep
spawning apparently but it's not worth
it whatever where did my fingers go oh
yeah they got bitten off
uh i guess this thing doesn't regrow
thingies all right
i'm coming man i don't even know this
guy's name but i'm i'm coming man
oh wait didn't that other thing have
like two
huh
oh oh
flashy flabloom all right boom hey dude
oh it's a pleasure to see you safe how
worthy
no sign of rose i'm so
sorry it turned out that way well
you'll find your way to her once you're
out of this castle
do you have need of anything for the
road ahead
thanks to your consistent patronage i've
expanded my services
okay that i don't know how i really want
to know how
you know i would love to know how yeah
whatever i i don't need to know how
also i need the ball sack to go in there
welcome
hi what do you have for me buddy
well this isn't expanded at all this is
not expanded what did you expand you
expanded nothing
all sorts of weapons modifications and
we'll do them for a small fee
you didn't expand [ __ ] you expanded dick
and diddle i'm gonna get that pistol
back eventually see i got all these good
things greatly increases firepower this
all seems like things that i should be
using
but i stupidly sold miley my but i don't
have really enough money to deal with it
now
i'll get it next time i didn't actually
sell my hearing goods is more important
than anything
uh-huh anything my friend anything
oh yeah i guess i'll sell it no
that's special ingrid necklace get no
that's right this is the weird thing
about me and gabe is like i feel like
something could be special if you find
anything else of value
okay we'll do buddy uh i think like
something could be of value so then i'm
i'm super hesitant to do that i don't
know if any of you guys are the same but
i just
i can't i can't bring myself to oh
uh is she gonna be coming the whole way
over
uh oh you know what maybe i should just
go maybe maybe maybe going is the best
i don't know why i didn't realize that
would start happening because you know
that's very much of the mr x from before
so
it's kind of like you know you know it's
kind of kind of
par for the course but uh for some
reason i wasn't
ready good thing they keep gunpowder in
such
decorative places well this looks like a
no oh it is a note
please be aware the mistress's lipstick
is missing if anyone finds it could they
please return it to her bathroom
it is custom made and therefore very
expensive
okay you think she'll get on her good
side if i bring her lipstick
well this looks very nice
hi one day since treatment the three
girls have stopped moving they
seem almost dead an insect flew out of
the eldest mouth it appears to be a
common fly
two days since treatment all three
bodies are covered in flies it appears
the flies are consuming their flesh
when i opened a window some of the flies
dropped dead to the floor it would seem
the cold petrifies them
i quickly closed the window to avoid
weakening the insects further four days
since treatment all three bodies have
almost
been completely consumed by the insects
all that is left is a dark writhing
human-shaped mass of creatures it is
just afternoon and the insects have
started to change color
those around the face have turned pale
and those around the lips turned to deep
crimson
six days since treatment the massive
insects have transformed into human
bodies again
all three girls awoke looking at me like
newborns i sense
a bond between us like mother and
daughters
oh i've already decided their names
bella daniela
and cassandra what great names what
great
story this is great love this
that's motherly love right there gosh
mobberly love
i see you man i really gotta like
get better at stabbing is there like a
like a stabbing upgrade that i could get
it'd be really convenient
they do get stunned after quite a few of
these pokey stabs
but it takes like 12 stabs to get him
dead
that's too many stabs hey lady demotress
here blinking a bit oh
i could do this okay
right yeah
oh no no no no no no
okay
[Music]
sorry i'm dumb
i did it i'm so lady demitrescu
pretty good right oh oh
wow that's the thing for the thing on
the things outside in the town and the
place in the church
in uh uh the right i don't know
scientific name
none five to six centimeters a similar
body structure to blowflies although
there are differences in the head there
carnivorous and vigorously consume
meat in order to catch unsuspecting prey
they'll gather using pheromones to mimic
a human
they are produced when a kaddu lays eggs
in its host
but the flies themselves are unable to
reproduce they are weak to sudden drops
in temperature
especially if the temperature drops
below 10 degrees celsius their
metabolism lowers and they go into a
dormant cryptobiotic state
similar to the cryptobiosis of
tardigrade or
polypedillum vanderpronky
yeah i'm familiar with the vanderplunky
who isn't familiar with that
don't think me some common rube hello
oh well i just circled back okay
oh that's down this place is just in a
horrid state of disrepair
there's a little more in the
quote-unquote
opera howl but i don't see it so i'm
going back
up the stairs oh i know wow
sorry led dammit rescue
an easy big lock i haven't been able to
get a lot of those
hello oh hello i'll be right there don't
you worry about the thing
i'll be right there oh you know
don't tell anybody about that no one
tell anybody that's secret
damn get stabbed right in the crotch
but hey hey whoa i blocked that why'd
that hurt so bad
uh hell i blocked that
[Music]
flower swords ball
it was a ball i can't believe that it's
so stupid that's so
dumb it's not like i was careless i was
very careful and i clicked
oh i would never shoot you i would never
shoot you my lady
hey look at this i know what this is
hurry hurry hurry hurry hurry she's very
large very large
very powerful very powerful very large
and you finally came to see me oh yeah
someone falls for me
you tell
you're right i'm so bad
okay so there's like covered up windows
oh what do we got here
hey stop stop stop stop
so mean i know where you going
where are you going where are you going
where'd you go
hello you okay
hi why are you doing this
you wanted to kill me what do you mean
why am i doing this
why are you so surprised
do what why would you do that you just
did that
that was pretty mean you really want to
kill me i mean do you want to kill me
these are all fair questions you know
and uh well this sure is easy
you kind of made this very easy you kind
of picked this place
whoa hey stop it you stop that
what don't you love me why would i
love you damn
hey don't don't don't don't don't
why are you so shocked every time that
happens this is a dream
yeah i'm a dream
well stop killing me then
yeah maybe if you uh i'm sick of bucks
all right anyway well that was fun
drafty in here all right let's get out
of here
sorry uh big mama i had to be done
you know just had to be done there's
nothing anybody could do about it hey
yeah i'm asking joy that makes sense
anyway what a weird statue hey what's on
that oh
did not expect that to actually open
what the hell
oh let the five bells of this chamber
ring out
okay i mean god damn
cool
ding okay that's one
where's another bell oh i probably gotta
shoot him
it's probably around the room somewhere
ah yep
bing
[Music]
oh i see it
well that's two oh i think i see one
there it is oh hey that's not in the
chamber
come on that's not in the chamber
yeah whatever that's cool you thought
you could hide why did i do
that
oh does lady dimitrescu have to do that
every time she wants to go
here where is here here is crap
all right cool also sorry about your
daughter well she wasn't really your
daughter or anything about it you really
think about it she wasn't really your
daughter
so you know not really not really family
who the [ __ ] is behind me who's behind
me oh
oh hey
are you searching for dragons
situation more like a kidnapping
situation so not really your daughter's
out that way
huh anyway hey watch out boom all right
cool i've
probably gotten like two percent of
those
take that man thing
take this man thing
apparently that's the insult of the day
around here
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah is that sniper ammo
hell yeah the crumbling really loud
hello treasure
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait easy
there buddy easy there buddy easy
treasure map okay dungeon kitchen wait a
minute
i was in the kitchen i was in the
dungeon there's an heirloom with a
fortune
in that nobleman's casket but there's a
damn trick to it
something about lighting
the way yeah okay all right sure i
believe you yeah this don't make sense
whatever hey yeah i ran the tit okay
i heard there was something called the
dagger of death's flowers somewhere in
the castle
it's apparently an antique from the
middle ages it's coated in a concoction
of poisons from across the continent
it's said to have been crafted to kill
demons and monsters it sounds
fascinating but
no one knows where it is i think i know
where it is i just found a treasure map
i would love the dagger of demon
dungaroos i what was it called again i
have no idea
oh yeah there there is space what are
you talking about and
move you there and move you there
there's space we don't give me that
[ __ ] about no
space there we go
man i'm really gonna never use this i'm
literally never going to use this
i'm i will be so scared of using this
ammo that i am legitimately
never going to use this gun i'm going to
resort back to the stabber
because that is all i know and all i
care about
oh god no
this place is bigger than i thought it
was i know they said it was a castle but
for some reason castle didn't really
resonate with my brain hole hello
very bloodborney you know very
bloodborne feels
i like it lot of crenellations and
buttresses hey bud
ah you're real you're real you're a real
boy
real boy for real boy
stab stab stab
okay well that was terrible all right so
maybe i will use these things well not
that
and equip okay
i gotta go kablooey these things
otherwise will they come after me now
i'll only do when they come after me
they ain't so tough i would never use my
sniper rifle i would never
oh no you're loot nope that was a loss
but yeah okay come on man
oh oh
oh my immersion is shattered this is
baloney this is malarkey everybody my my
entire gaming experience has been
ruined truly truly
[Laughter]
alas it's it tis the watch
tills tis what it is you know
is what it is hey what's up dude
boom hahaha what are you doing how are
you doing right now come on come here
come on come on come on come on oh yeah
yeah like that's gonna work
oh god oh
you're dead oh yeah yeah you're dead ah
waste a bullet
what these things i don't think they
program these quite right
i don't think these things work properly
okay all right hey what's up yeah you
want some now
these things seem a little bit uh
underdeveloped you know
i need a little bit longer in the game
oven
[Applause]
give me your loot weird tongue face
thing
i'm just gonna run for it because
apparently these things will just
kill themselves on the geometry before
they'll actually be a threat to me
so uh later nerds that my friend on the
floor oh no
just someone else they're so camera shy
hi what's up all right
try this yeah my good why
what
how where am i oh
masquerade i definitely knew i was
coming here for that
i definitely knew that thank you i won't
use it though
i'm not gonna use the latter i'll just
jump down
all right cool good job guys all right
later nerds later nerds
see you later douches uh game developers
i think that section needs a little work
aerial combat doesn't seem to be your
specialty
the re engine seems a little limited in
that capacity
i mean i'm not gonna lie that was that
was pretty abysmal
that was that was pretty bad take this
dimitrescu
uh did i get it no okay
oh man thing you won't live long
even if you run uh well oh shoot
oh no not me not me
all right excuse my uh my seemingly
viciousness way of speaking it was if
you think about it actually
quite masculine welcome welcome
sure to find something new yeah i found
this uh
ball what
what what what
what
wha what i love this
i love this also i hear the thunders
kabooms
oh wait oh [ __ ] hang on almost there
there we go i did it
get the ball i did it wow
that's got to be worth a thing or two
let me say before i sell it
someone's real pissed uh
lady demetreski let me do
let lady dome let lady dim
okay you nervous at all
no no you ain't nervous why would you be
if it's just looking window
shop away yeah how much is this uh
crimson skull worth um all right cool
uh you want these things all right i'm
gonna buy this thing back
um oh wait no no this is gonna seem
weird i know i bought this but i'm gonna
sell this just because
it does take up some space and i could
probably just buy back
you no longer need this yeah what are
you buying
just something an old friend of mine
used to say [ __ ]
shut up shut up shut up shut up you shut
up you
shut your mouth hablamow
nice okay i already have another upgrade
please come again
okay equip part this thing
nice okay that increases the dabblage
okay this is gonna seem really weird
i don't want this sniper rifle it's
gonna seem very strange i don't want it
i don't like sniper rifles i don't i
i just don't i don't know why
i know that i have like the thing the
dangly thing on it but how do i
can you take that off what does it even
do
what what does it do am i upgraded leave
this to me yeah yeah okay
okay i somehow have enough to upgrade
literally all
modification can be done in just a
moment man i have a lot of money
also why don't you sell any more bullets
equip for a
dangly charm okay so that it literally
does nothing it does nothing
except dangle and it's annoying or
whatever whatever whatever whatever
i have good pistol good day to you
because this does way more damage than
the other one i think and then the
sniper rifle like i just don't like
sniper rifles i i'm weird like that
i just i can't stand them hey
ma'am how are you
[Music]
yeah maybe you know you might be right
you you might be right about that
you might be right about that that's my
bad
are you gonna stay there long madam i
would never
shoot you i would never you still there
i'm going for it i'm gonna run for it
i'm running for it but
do i have this oh god oh god oh god okay
okay oh god oh god i gotta look
that's fine okay you're three okay good
you're three you're one okay single no
place left to run
where are you oh wow you are so stay
right there so
chunk you're
so beautiful oh you're
so beautiful all right i gotta
i know that there was a yeah is this the
uh is this the you know the thing to the
thing
and the thing with the thing and the
thing here oh i didn't unlock that
hey would you like some wine ma'am ma'am
ma'am
ma'am okay
madame dede
[Music]
i'm kind of i'm kind of caught in kind
of caught uh here
this is kind of a problem big big bro oh
well this is also
uh oh man oh wow you know this
please not like this not like this
missed me by that much missed me by
that much okay where the hell am i going
where in the hell am i going
okay so in the basement they said
something about in the basement
that there was like things this main
hall that way kitchen kitchen kitchen
kitchen
okay that's right this way leads
if i go this way and then this way leads
to
i'm an idiot how did i go the wrong way
there
how did i do that how did i do that how
did i do that please
yep that's me i'm so nimble
nimbled me quick nimble medic oh god
all right so yeah there's a secret up
here something about lighting the way
they said so i gotta light
the way um yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh
oh my god what were the all these
upgrades for
what was it about it said something
about pushing pushing things back with
space but it doesn't seem to
how did i do that all right whatever
let's go let's go let's go okay
so apparently in this casket there's
okay okay okay there's something here
yeah okay so there's fire over there and
there's fire over here
oh pipe bomb well that's what we need
this for obviously this this seems
pretty clear to me
equip and then throw it yep
i knew it who the hell
do you think you are
hey i need that
there we go here we go oh come on the
physics is just
a little janky here there we go
use this to light the other one
oh my god how is the momentum die that
quick
on these things oh my god
oh my god there we go
good golly hello can i have your knife
oh uh well that's not what i was
expecting to find in here an
azure eye why so many skulls in here
dude
why are there so many skulls in here
all right cool well that's not
what the hell do i need an azure eye for
well that's disappointing well not
really disappointing i don't really know
what it means
okay so what's my objective oh find the
four angel masks that's what it is
well that's some oh who
where why okay hang on hang on hang on
where have i not
been yet ah i didn't put the other
mask in three-prong mask so i might as
well do that
oh and it's kind of a clue of where it
is angel of pleasure
appreciates art best kept behind a
gilded door
oh where the hell am i well this is
interesting
gilded door oh this is the where i
originally was
oh there's there's going to work up my
appetite are you
who the hell do you think you are
ah stop stop stop
stop stop
stop stop i'm not but i think you're
just
stop
how did you i don't understand anything
that's happening here
how did i unlock that but how did i
wait where am how oh ah oh
okay gilded door gildy dory
let me go back um this in way
i know there's got to be more places
that i have not
fully seen yet gilded door i mean these
oh
wait listen oh what is this
that's a big ass tub that's a flippin
big old tub good god that's a tub of
lubber
oh lip oh sticker
i remember a little lady demetrescu i've
got something that you're gonna
you're gonna appreciate you got really
you're gonna really appreciate this lady
well i'm lost
the hall of pleasure the hall of
pleasure okay
i need to go to the whole pl the right
it's the angel the mask of
pleasure okay so i gotta go i gotta go
over i know where exactly where that is
and i know exactly who's gonna be
standing in my way
you will learn what it means salt house
stomach press
i think i've already learned what that
means madame dimitrescu
i don't know why she's so mad at me you
know i i really don't understand i've
been nothing but respectful her
she sliced my freako hand off and uh
you know that's just not cool that's
just not cool you know i gotta admit
it's it's really not
cool of all the not cool things i've
seen oh
hell yeah it was right here right there
the mask of pledge we love it you love
it
i love it we all love it
[Music]
oh wait a minute wait a minute
uh interesting can i combine this with
the i
combine oh yeah
i did something what did i do
very very oh it's just valuable that's
it that's not a
dagger ah but i want the dagger of death
the dagger of doom and death that's what
i want
fine all right hello
could i put this armor on it might help
me
i was worried my sisters had gotten to
you first
well they didn't sorry
hey what's up
hey stop oh wait am i dead wait what the
hell
maybe i'll keep a souvenir wait what do
you mean i'm dead what the hell just
happened i was at full health
what happened the frick happened
what do you mean
i was legit i was at full health you
can't kill me in one shot i'm uneasy
what the dude what happened what
happened to me
my guys what happened okay i was worried
my sisters have gotten
okay okay powerful attack yep there's
pipe bombs here
i know i know the deal here i know here
we go and
it's my friends oh
did she just go [ __ ] man the way these
things attack my frame rate directly
it's very yu-gi-oh but also very
annoying
all right let's take take two
oh what i didn't oh my god i didn't want
to do that
hang on okay let's do this i'm just
worried my sisters are gone
no oh no no way
yeah that's what you get lady that's
what you get
i never ruined it if you think about it
yeah if you think about if you really
think about it i ain't ruined no hunt
no no no
yes
creepy maybe if i
gave these all back the lady didn't
trust coo she would be very happy
you know maybe instead of daughters you
know
a son i'm just running out there anyway
what do i do where am i going
it's kind of blocked off here what do i
do wait what's happening where
am i crazy wait oh what yeah i was
supposed to know this
oh yeah okay yeah that makes total sense
mounted skull
why do i have mounted skull what
why
uh-huh
interesting or now why does this have
four but also this has
four that's interesting hang on a second
bang one moment please
okay i should be able to get out with
these what
was this like locked okay i didn't even
notice that but
okay apparently oh
hello ma'am the entire bloodline of the
house
is done in by the likes of you
hello no not nice ass i respect its
power
i respect the power of the butt
hello would you like a mask of pleasure
sure does look like that
anyway let me go save and whatnot and
something
i shall okay okay for that
let me combine my a good deal
okay cool welcome how much more valuable
was this
excessively more great cool thank you
ladies lipstick very valuable i won't
get rid of that just yet
but i don't think there's anything else
that i need besides maybe more bag
congratulations with this you'll not
worry a good day then
i mean you don't really have a lot of
stuff for me to not get rid of
but
yeah yeah whoa that's cool
all right um well uh uh that's a good
stopping point here uh don't know where
we're going now but um uh seems dramatic
so
yeah thank you everybody so much for
watching i hope you enjoyed this one uh
have a lovely day have a lovely life
take care of yourselves take care of
each other
and as always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye